sanders e benvenuti in un nuovissimo
dopo il video sulle unghie più strane
del mondo mi avete letteralmente
invaso di video di unghie ancora più
terrificanti che io dico cioè pensavo di
aver raggiunto già il baratro con il
video della scorsa volta ma non è così
c'è molto di peggio in giro ma non
perdiamoci in chiacchiere e andiamo
subito al sodo non ci bastavano le
banane il cipollotto e il porro ci
voleva qualcosa che lasciasse ancora di
più il segno o meglio il tanfo perché
non farci una bella ricostruzione con un
fantastico
spicchio d'aglio se noi vogliamo puzzare
prendiamo lo spicchio invece di buttarlo
in padella con l'olio cielo su via ci
chiamò sull'unghia poi andiamo di generi
copriamo il tutto per conservare al
meglio il sapore e
l'aroma pungente di questo fantastico
aglio che io sia appassionata di catene
ormai lo sapevate le catene o le mette
ovunque alcol sulle borse mi piacciono
tantissimo ma non credo che sarei pronta
a una ricostruzione del genere perché
queste unghie che possono sembrare quasi
normali hanno un buco e poi da questo
buco è stato attaccato una catenina e tu
dici che cosa c'è alla fine di queste
catenine io mi immagino una
rivisitazione di crudelia demon è
praticamente alla fine di queste catene
ci sono i tre dalmata quindi invece di
portarli in giro tenendoli per mano tu
venite qua e chirico si capito così mal
che vada chi parte o lunga non la uso da
un po di anni ma la pinzatrice di base
il problema della pinzatrice per me era
che non avevo mai le graffette da
metterci dentro adesso ho capito perché
non ne trovavo mai perché a quanto pare
c'è questa ragazza che le ruba per farsi
le unghie
il folletto delle caffetterie presente
tipo quei film fantasy dove dove sono
finite a fette
certi poteri vale prende poi a casa va
nel suo laboratorio e si fa la
ricostruzione con le graffette è anche
molto semplice da fare perché tu buster
metti il brand il proprio dalla scatola
delle graffette la fila di grafite
trafitti ri lì mi fai tutte le cose qua
c'è comunque ha un suo perché
hai bisogno delle cassette con la presa
di taglio il pezzetto che ti serve non è
il caso di togliersi tutta l'unghia che
puoi tenertela un pezzettino infine la
pinzatrice e vai come se non ci fosse
domani io non so se questa ragazza sia
una fan dei film disney in particolare
di peter pan però questo mi sembra un
chiaro omaggio a capitan uncino e posso
dire la trovo anche per certi versi
affascinante è un chino tutti gli
effetti un uncino rock è un uncino
decorato con dei brillocchi è un porta
nelli all'ultimo frame ci voglio andare
a farmi un giro nel ras posto con gli
anelli più lenti lily che te li porti
dentro l'uncino nell'unghia trovo
geniale l'altra volte se non sbaglio
avevamo le arachidi questa volta ci
giochiamo i pistacchi i pistacchi cioè
capito e come potete vedere lei mette
primato non sopra l'altro i distacchi
poi cosa fa però li ricopre ma non
rilascia così
gira e toglie il pistacchio dentro
certamente
perché se non poteva già toglierlo prima
lei giustamente vuole soltanto la parte
superiore a no quindi aspetta di
appiccicare tutto e poi ti toglie pisana
perché si rimangia
siete parrucchieri o parrucchiere avete
fatto con meani danza classica beh
allora questi queste per voi non sono
forcine sono
utensili da lavoro
ecco lei decide di omaggiare le forcine
di una ricostruzione fantastica
precisamente parliamo di quattro porcine
applicate sull'unghia che una volta poi
limata
ecco l'effetto c'è una volta finita non
mi sa molto di forcina mi sa più di
sfumatura de non si vedono benito è però
effettivamente mancavano le fragole in
questa macedonia di ricostruzioni ecco
mi piace perché questa si vede
chiaramente è una bella fragola della
basilicata di quelle belle fragolone
abbondanti e lei decide non di prima di
tagliare direttamente il pezzo come
andava attaccare sul ungarici attacca
tutto il fragolone e poi una volta ha
ricoperto con il gel decide allora lì
poi di limare lunga ed il mare anche i
lati e di fare un po un succo di fragola
e c'è anche una decorazione con dei nomi
sono stati dei brillantini che sembrano
un po ricordano i semini della fragola e
devo dire che di quelle viste fino ad
ora
così non è proprio
malvagia
che dite non lo escluderei
ecco qui qui iniziano a vacillare le
parole perché questo è fango iniettato
dentro l'unghia no non so se sia fango
meno però è un unghia trasparente con un
buco e lei con una siringa va a riempire
l'unghia di un liquido che voglio dire
con tutti i liquidi di colore carini che
ci poteva essere in giro le sceglie il
verde marcianò cos'è beige tortora
insomma ti fa pensare a tutto tranne che
alla freschezza e alla pulizia potrebbe
essere cioccolato potrebbe essere
caffé d'orzo potrebbe essere fango
probabile attendono i commenti le vostre
supposizioni su questo liquido di dubbia
provenienza che la signorina si inietta
nelle
ultimi saranno i primi ed è per questo
che voglio finire il video con questo
unghia
come dire quest'opera d'arte
contemporanea molto visionaria lei lei
va oltre lei usa gli scovolini del
mascara per ricostruire lunga ma
aggiunge anche delle delle ciglia finte
lima sopra e sotto e
io credo che lo scovolino del mascara
dentro lunga in trasparenza
effettivamente sia il livello proprio
superiore purtroppo il momento arde nel
mio canale finisce qui nel senso però
oggi però vi conosco visto che mi avete
inondato di unghie di queste unghie che
vi fa vedere oggi mi manderete di
altrettante lunghe perché la ragazza ha
voglia di sperimentare ultimamente l'ha
detto molto sul pezzo quindi ci
potrebbero essere resi quel questa
fantastica serie sulle unghie
vi mando un bacio amici e amiche delle
unghie e ci vediamo al prossimo
video